is the author of the forthcoming book
how i save the world which desperately
needs saving by jesse waters you can
pre-order it now and we hope you will
because this is wise and funny as he is
jesse waters good to see you did you
have masks
and vaccination cards at your wedding
i did not uh although there was a lot of
dancing
and i think i speak for both of us
tucker two white guys with no rhythm
this is actually a great excuse for us
not to hit the dance floor we can just
say ladies sorry
it's the law just trying to slow the
spread but for
the rest of the people of the country
especially
middle-aged dads weddings are the only
time of year that you can bust a move
and not be totally humiliated
because you're in a safe space with
friends and family
you're not at a club with good dancers
so when nelly drops
nellie's a rapper tucker you can really
let loose and not be ashamed of yourself
because
freedom of expression is enshrined in
our founding
documents and if i want to express
myself by doing the hustle
the macarena or dare i say the electric
slide i think that's constitutionally
protected they told us all last summer
that these peaceful protests were forms
of expression and they destroyed
whole cities so surely i should be able
to destroy a dance floor
or two i don't know um
has a democrat ever been to a wedding
they're going to say
the bride and the groom they can't dance
an hour later they're going to be
consummating the marriage upstairs
and from what i know that has to be
a little closer than six feet maybe just
i'm not sure wait wait i want to
i want to stop you right there and i
don't i don't want to get into sex ed
live on tv but you did just see the vice
president united states
kiss her husband as they both wore masks
so it's by no means certain that the
consummation will be maskless
is it it that is not certain
tucker and i don't know if you
understand this because you probably
fly private but i was on an airplane the
other day when i was moving
and scooching through the aisle i was
making sustained physical contact
with a perfect stranger i don't do that
on the dance floor
i was watching the laker game the other
day lebron james backing a guy down into
the post
i don't make that kind of contact on the
dance floor it depends on
what song that is but where's the line
i mean we have kids in cages at the
border if the kids in cages start
dancing is that it
is that a crisis then back to guatemala
that's the one
offense that can get you deported in
ayatollah muriel bowser's america
dancing in cages and by the way our
viewers are going to want to run into
you on southwest i have the i have this
feeling that they know there's an
opportunity
there won't be any fists thrown there
trust me
the great jesse waters thank you very
much hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else